hey everybody I've been getting a lot of
requests to do new preview video for
infinity war Marvel just dropped the
mother lode of infinity war content but
there's so much of it that I'll just
focus on the biggest stuff in this video
I'll talk about the new trailer that
they're gonna be dropping really soon we
learn more about that and then I'll just
do the rest of the stuff in a different
video because we got all that new stuff
about Iron Man soul gem weird promos
that they're releasing so that's gonna
be a separate video this will be all the
brand new stuff that they dropped this
morning but if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there's even an Infinity
Gauntlet replica giveaway that's going
on all you have to do to enter that is
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so starting with the big
stuff first like I'm just gonna go
through all this as we go along so some
of this is armor upgrades deeper dives
and some of this is new footage so here
we go starting with Thanos we actually
learned where they are where they're
fighting him here on this crazy barren
Rock this is actually the ruins of his
homeworld of Titan and here's a really
key part Kevin Feige actually explained
that the reason why Thanos is assembling
the infinity gems is specific to what
happened to his home planet of Titan so
this is a big comic book change Kevin
Feige explained that something happened
to the Titans race that caused them to
go extinct in the event was something
that Thanos was not allowed to prevent
he vowed never to let that happen again
and sees the universe going down the
tubes because life is expanding
unchecked so that's where they get back
on the comic book track the reason why
Thanos needs to reshape the universe is
because he's so pissed off about the
extinction of his race which is a bit of
a twist because in the comics he
actually killed everyone on his home
planet himself so he's not quite as much
of a psycho as he was in the comics so
if you don't know that as his backstory
he flows from the Eternals mythology
which is like a really deep Jack Kirby
cut but what happened is as Jack Kirby
left Marvel to do new gods at DC then he
came back to Marvel and did the Eternals
the Eternals is a race or like this
offshoot of humanity created by the
Celestials so this gets back to big
Celestials MCU stuff the Celestials have
sort of like this cosmic order where
they go around seeding planets and then
every once in a while they'll come back
and check on their progress and they'll
either
Troi the world if they don't feel like
that it has any potential or in the case
of the earth they'll continue to allow
it to flourish like okay the thing that
we seeded is actually turning into
something great
so the Eternals moved to Saturn's moon
Titan and that became their homeworld
there was an offshoot of their race
called the deviants Thanos was born to
the leader of the Eternals race mentor
and his wife there was a comic book that
recently revealed what Thanos true name
was meant to be but when he exited his
mother's womb she saw him and
immediately went mad but whispered his
name later when he came back to kill her
so Thanos was intended to be like this
great gift of love to the universe but
became this really twisted thing so is
this really twisted story on Greek
mythology like Thanos gets into some
really high mythology in the Marvel
Universe so within the MCU I'm expecting
a lot of Easter eggs for his back story
in the comics although they tend to
simplify things a lot but what a lot of
people have now guessed is is that this
planet shot that we get at the beginning
of the infinity war trailer is this
wreckage that they're fighting in during
the movie and it has something to do
with the soul gem now it actually seems
like this either is Xander or it is
Titan I mean there's not quite enough
footage to distinguish between those two
places but there is a giant battle based
on the description of this picture that
Marvel provided that takes place on
Santos's home planet of Titan so for
some reason Thanos is there and the
Avengers go there to fight him pretty
safe bet that it has something to do
with the infinity gems but as we
suspected this is going to be a big
battle in Wakanda so this happens
separately from that even though most of
the Avengers are gonna be present during
this as well as the guardians of the
galaxy but I just love the idea that
Thanos is going to hook a moon at them
while they're fighting like the CG for
this obviously looks much more finished
than what we've seen in the trailer so
far so I wouldn't be surprised if
there's a more polished version of this
in the next trailer that we get because
they showed off a primitive version of
it during Comic Con last year this is
just a better picture of mustache Bros
rallying outside the sanctum when Thanos
his ship comes into orbit they just call
it a mysterious ship but obviously we
know it belongs to Thanos so they
actually provide a timeline for how this
all comes together to like win whole
crashes the reason that Iron Man winds
up in the sanctum so what they say is is
the Doctor Strange summons Tony Stark
before the
crashes into the sanctum so if you
haven't read the pre lewd story that
Marvel released for this a couple weeks
ago I'll add a link for that at the end
of this I've already done a video about
it it explains how Doctor Strange knows
that there's this grand cosmic unease
because of Thanos mission to assemble
the gems so in the moments leading up to
the beginning of infinity war Doctor
Strange has an idea for what's going on
the reason Tony Stark is freaking out is
because he's still thinking about the
vision that Scarlet Witch gave him back
during age of Ultron so they both have
an idea for what's going on but Doctor
Strange actually knows about the
Infinity stones Tony Stark knows a
little bit less because he studied the
mind gem he accidentally created Ultron
but he also had a chance to study the
space gem back when it was still the
tesseract in the first Avengers film the
moustache bros meet then hulk crashes
into the sanctum then immediately after
that the mysterious ship appears in
orbit and you get your battle here so
we've seen a little bit of that during
the trailer already we don't have a
timeline for when this picture takes
place because we know that they come
back with vision after that big fight
with the Black Order and they try to
take the mine gem so this could be
happening before that it could be
happening after they bring vision back
to the New Avengers facility but you get
a shot of Rhodey with his new harness
that helps him walk because his spine is
still damaged but he's none the worse
for wear I mean he's still the same old
Rhodey like he was cracking why it's the
end of civil war are you Tony thank yes
this is this is Tony stank you're in the
right place thank you for that never
dropping that by the way table for one
mr. stank but as you can imagine this is
the moment where they effectively bury
that Civil War hatchet so whatever
differences they had before they're all
on the same page at this moment this is
actually a big one marvel's describing
this is Shuri meeting with the Hulk in
Scarlet which for the first time so I'm
assuming this is after they brought
vision to akanda because he still has
the mind gem and they need sharees
technology to help protect him and find
out how to separate him from the mind
gem without completely destroying his
personality because we saw all those
funny shots of banner climbing out of
the Hulkbuster so that's like a
completely separate thing the Hulk
wearing the Hulk Buster but this just
confirms that they bring vision to
Wakanda and provides us with the reason
forth and ohsas outriders to invade so
if you don't know who these big forearm
creatures are these
the outriders from the comics they just
given them a giant upgrade in the movie
so these are like the CG creatures that
they're just gonna lay into with all
their crazy weapons the clips that they
have are a little out of order so
obviously this is pretty
self-explanatory this is after
spider-man on the bus to school sees
that giant ship in the sky and it's like
holy crap I got to help out we'll just
pretend like the other kids on the bus
don't notice that he hops out spider-man
style through that small opening and
then puts a spider-man mask on while
he's hanging on to the side of the bus
just like spider-man would probably
gonna be a couple questions he's gonna
have to answer back at school the next
time everyone shows up what are you
hiding Peter but the way Marvel's
describing this clip is it just Tom
Hollands spider-man springing into
action during a class field trip when he
spots a strange queue ship I love it the
way they call it a queue ship is if it's
shaped like an actual queue but then
Marvel actually in their description
says with the help of his iron spider
armor he manages to clamor on to the
ominous machine so they make it sound
like he actually uses the iron spider
armor to get on that ship even though
we've seen him on the ship in the
classic suit that he got during
homecoming so I'm assuming that he gets
on the ship in the old costume then the
iron spider armor attaches to him we get
to see all the cool stuff that it does
but it's what helps him continue to hang
on to the ship otherwise he like
completely falls off like it looks like
he's getting ready to do right here the
gauntlets on the iron spider armor look
hardcore giving you an idea for what
color his legs look like like there was
a brief look that we got of it but this
isn't totally accurate because it's
artist's rendering it's not like a
full-blown picture that you see right
out of the movie or the way they group
some of these characters is actually
pretty interesting they do a little
foreshadowing without outright telling
you what the plot of the movie is going
to be like star-lord with a coy way of
black panther so pretty safe bet that
the guardians will be part of this giant
final battle with Thanos in Wakanda I
love the way that they only included two
gems and Thanos has gauntlet here but
this isn't a picture this is an artist's
rendering so they could have made this
look like whatever they want like please
don't show him with all the gems in the
gauntlet we don't want people to think
that he's gonna be collecting every one
of them during infinity war we get a way
better look at winter soldiers vibranium
arm I know it looks kind of blue in this
image here but this is
a much better picture of it up close I
would be willing to bet that it does a
lot more than just help him grab on to
stuff so just imagine Inspector Gadget
style what are the things Winter Soldier
vibranium arm can do as well much better
look at Iron Man's costume obviously a
lot of these attachments can turn into
different things because the suit just
comes straight out of the arc reactor
with nanites so let me know what you
think about all that and brand new
trailer is probably coming next week or
the week after that there was a disney
shareholders meeting where they were
talking about all their lines of
business so what will happen is is
there'll be more infinity war posting in
the next couple of days and I'll
announce the giveaway winner when I post
a new Marvel but click here for the
breakdown of that infinity war prelude
story it's all about the infinity gems
and you can click here for that brand
new infinity war promo thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]